ratna cartoon says the german river used
to flow through where she is now
standing
and she and her family could farm here
before but now it's full of illegally
extracted sand
her husband now drives a rickshaw card
to make a living
and they struggle to support their
family of six
they illegally took away all the sand
from the riverbed using trucks
after dredging and creating a sinkhole
which makes the river unstable
all this is now destroying our homes and
farms in the area
the extracted sand is also used to fill
in wetlands that people then lay claim
to
uncontrol and mostly illegal sand
extraction from river beds
for construction and land fillings are
killing rivers and farmlands across
bangladesh
raw gold as the sand lifters call it
does not cost them much to extract
but fetches good money villagers have
held protest in recent days against
dredging in the tungal district
sometimes illegal sand mining is carried
out with support from
elected officials abdulrahman khan
fought in the war of independence
against pakistan in 1971
he says he's losing ancestral land
because of the german river being
dredged
by local authorities
they are illegally dredging our land to
make a new way for the river
ignoring a high court decision they are
grabbing our ancestor land by force
without paying any compensation to the
villages
the bangladesh department of environment
did not reply to al jazeera's request
for an interview
environment lawyers say weak regulation
and lack of law enforcement
is partly to blame sand mining is
largely
unregulated here in bangladesh whatever
weak legal framework we have that is not
followed either in leasing out a sand
mine or
in monitoring the actual mining activity
as a result we are losing
many uh streams of rivers sand mining
and the heavy machinery
used in extraction are changing the
course of rivers and eroding them we are
destroying our rice field by dumping the
sand in our farmland we are requesting
compensation from the prime minister for
the damage
it's our ancestral land we have all the
documents to prove it
one percent of agriculture land in
bangladesh
is disappearing every year because of
its fast-growing economy
and rapid urbanization according to the
urban development foundation
ceud and the un's environment agency
says
the global demand for sand and gravel of
between 40 billion and 50 billion tons a
year
is an emerging crisis for the world with
the constant depletion of farmland and
the rise in river eruptions
many here say bangladesh will face a
major challenge in the future
in growing the food it will need sanvi
choudhary al-jazeera jamuna river bank
shiraj gange